Das ist wirklich eine überraschende entdeckung dazu noch ein kosmischer rekord ein amerikanisches forschungsteam hat jetzt ein super
massereiches schwarzes loch entdeckt neben seiner gigantischen masse sind auch die helligkeit und das alter dieses quasars
rekordverdächtig es ist wohl mehr als
13 milliarden jahre alt wie das forschungsteam dem massemonster auf die schliche gekommen ist welche
Mysteriöse rätsel ist uns aufgibt und was diese entdeckung über die entstehung unseres universums verrät
jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Seine kennung york 13 42 + 09
28 klingt unspektakulär
Doch seine entdeckung ist umso spektakulärer es geht tatsächlich
Um das fernste und älteste schwarze loch das die menschheit je aufgespürt hat es ist mehr als
13 milliarden lichtjahre von uns entfernt
das licht war also tatsächlich
13 milliarden jahre unterwegs
Bis es die erde erreicht hat als das massemonster. Also seine strahlung aussandte war das universum
Wo sie gerade einmal 6 190 millionen jahre jung das entspricht etwa fünf prozent des heutigen
alters entdeckt wurde das rekord schwarze loch von einem amerikanischen
forschungsteam das in chile nach kasan gesucht hatte ja mir ja schon öfter einmal darüber berichtet quasare sind quasi die kerne weit
entfernte aktiver galaxien die ein gigantisches schwarzes loch in ihrem zentrum haben sie zählen zu den hellsten objekte
Im kosmos was bedeutet dass sie über milliarden lichtjahre hinweg sichtbar sind trotzdem
gestaltet sich die suche nach
Ihnen als sehr kompliziert bislang sind nur rund 100 jahren bekannt die älter als zwölf milliarden jahre
Sind klare lassen sich nicht durch die aufnahme
optischer teleskope entdecken sondern durch infrarot teleskope der grund ihre große rotverschiebung die
Spektralanalyse des neu entdeckten fahrers ergab eine rotverschiebung von
7,54 durch dieses ergebnis konnte das forschungsteam auf sein alter rückschließen wie gesagt
690 millionen jahre astronomen und astronomen bezeichnen diese zeit als die epoche der realisierung eine umbruchszeit
des kosmos den bis dahin neutralen
wasserstoffgas wurden elektronen geraubt und zwar durch das sehr intensive licht der jungen sterne dadurch
Ionisierte das wasserstoffgas wie genau diese prozesse damals abliefen ist zum größten teil noch
ungeklärt doch die aktuelle entdeckung gibt neue hinweise auf diese phase denn die analyse seines lichts deutet darauf hin dass ein teil des
wasserstoffs noch neutral gewesen sein muss das würde modelle stützen die davon ausgehen dass die sogenannte re
ionisierung eher spät in der kosmischen geschichte stattgefunden hat dazu die interpretation des forschungsteams
Die tatsache dass beide bisher bekannten quasaren mit einer rotverschiebung z größer sieben hinweise
auf neutralen wasserstoff zeigen bestätigt dass wir sind unsere beobachtung bis in die epoche der
Realisierung vorgedrungen sind doch der masse gigant ist noch in weiterer hinsicht
Außergewöhnlich nach den berechnungen des astronomie teams setzt der quasi rund 40 billionen mal so viel energie
Frei wie die sonne und zwar pro sekunde die analyse des amerikanischen
Forschungsteams ergab aber nicht nur dass es nicht nur sehr hell sondern auch sehr massereich ist genauer soll es rund 8
millionen sonnenmassen anfassen unfassbar wenn man das beispielsweise mit dem schwarzen loch
im zentrum der milchstraße also unserer galaxie vergleicht das hat nämlich nur knapp vier millionen sonnenmassen
Und diese gigantische masse stellt die forscherinnen und forscher für ein großes rätsel denn mit unseren bisherigen wissen lässt sich nicht erklären
Wie das damals noch, so junge universum ein solch massereiches schwarzes loch
produzieren konnte die berechnung könnten also darauf hinweisen dass frühe schwarze löcher
Doch schneller wachsen als bislang gedacht doch das ist nur eine vermutung die entstehung solcher
massereichen schwarzen löcher ist und bleibt wohl erst einmal eines der größten rätsel der astrophysik doch trotzdem haben schon die ersten
analysen des quasars super spannende informationen über die frühzeit
Des kosmos geliefert das ziel der forscherinnen und forscher ist es jetzt weitere außergewöhnliche
Quasaren zu entdecken dies könnte zukünftig mit sensibleren instrumenten als bisher noch ein
Engagieren wenn ihr kein video zu schwarzen löchern und da gibt es immer wieder welche uns auch
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann sollten wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht dem
auf die glocken und dann verpasst er kein video geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken dunkle materie
Rätsel löst spielen schwarze löcher eine rolle eine sehr spannende these und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran